as investigators picked through the
bombed out remains of the cafe where
military blogger Maxim fomen otherwise
known as vladin tatasky was killed the
hunt was on for this girl Daria trepova
seen here carrying the small statue
thought to be filled with explosives
which she'd presented to tatarski
shortly before the bomb went off
the question is whether the 26 year old
knew what the statue contained
in a statement released clearly under
duress she admitted she'd brought the
statue to the cafe but refused to say
who'd given it to her
Russia's investigative committee claims
that trepova was working together with
Ukraine Security Services and with
Alexei navalny's anti-corruption
Foundation which is labeled both as a
foreign agent and an extremist
organization in Russia her husband
believes that she was framed
Street Food Bar number one once belonged
to Wagner boss Evgeni Prego
as he hoisted the flag over the
Ukrainian town of bakmut claiming he'd
finally captured it he dedicated the
flag to tatasky's memory adding this in
a separate audio message
[Music]
so tatarski will have had many enemies a
former convict originally from
machiaveka near Donetsk he had fought in
separatist battalions against Ukraine
since 2014 and as an ultra-nationalist
blogger he did not shy away from
criticism of Russia's military command
either
Kiev denies involvement but on the
Russian front lines his name was
remembered
McNay Sky News Moscow